vielen dank für die vorstellung der
titel würde schon genannt mir geht es in
einem vortrag um die frage
was jetzt digitale lehre eigentlich ist
und kann wenn wir auf das digitale
medium reflektieren und hier stellt sich
mir die frage wie es im titel bereits
angegeben ist ist es eine technik ist es
schon aber was ist es hauptsächlich ist
es ein medium das thema unseres team
postens oder ist es gar an lebensform
und ich möchte diese fragen diskutieren
in dem ich sie auf den begriff der
virtuellen realität beziehe der mich
sehr interessiert aus der perspektive
der heute auch schon ein paar mal
angeklungen ist der aber notorisch
unklar ist und ich möchte versuchen ein
bisschen mehr licht in diesen dunklen
begriff zu bringen ob dies gelingt wird
man dann wenn die sehen ja mein vortrag
hat für teile ist möchte ich auf die
realität funktion auf die reale
bedeutung der insbesondere neuen medien
zu sprechen kommt dann möchte ich medien
als form von virtueller realität
diskutieren dann möchte ich diese
virtuelle lehre wird mit der realität
auf die lehre beziehen insbesondere auf
die hochschullehre und abschließend
möchte ich ein paar beispiele aus meiner
didaktischen erfahrung der letzten jahre
an der lmu münchen berichten
zuerst zur frage nach der realität der
neuen medien ist immer mehr in der
letzten zeit in der kultur wissenschaft
hervorgetreten dass medien nicht nur
zwischen sender und empfänger vermitteln
wir hatten da auch ein vortrag der
zwölfjährigen sondern dass sie eine
performative dimension besitzen wenn sie
also selbst realität erzeuger gibt es
dieses bekannte motto von manchen
regionen diesen bekannten
kulturtheoretiker der 60er jahre dem
medium is the message
also das medium ist gar nicht so an
zweiter stelle
es ist das eigentliche worum es geht es
hat eine eigene anthologie eine eigene
performative dimension und dann möchte
ich jetzt anknüpfen vor allem im blick
auf die neuen medien die bei mclaren
schon ein bisschen im zentrum waren aber
zum internet hat sie denn natürlich noch
nicht viel mitbekommen können jetzt hat
luciano flori die der bekannte internet
theoretiker folgendes über den neuen
medien gesagt was ich sehr treffend
findet sie die neuen medien schaffen und
prägen unsere geistige und materielle
wirklichkeit verändern unser
selbstverständnis
modifizieren die wir miteinander in
beziehung treten und uns auch ihn selbst
beziehen und sie bringen unsere welt
deutschland auf einen neuen besseren
stand und das tun sie eben so
tiefgreifend wie umfassend und
unablässig ich glaube die ist hier
nichts hinzuzufügen ist es im jahr 2015
geäußert worden sechs jahre später und
durch kroner denke ich kann man das noch
mehr bestätigen und jetzt stellt sich
die frage was für eine bedeutung haben
diese neuen medien gerade für die lehre
dazu möchte ich jetzt kurz eine
virtuelle umfrage machen und zwar die
frage heißt folgendermaßen was
assoziieren sie mit virtueller realität
hierzu habe ich jetzt wir haben darüber
schon gesprochen einem elfmeter umfragen
gemacht wenn sie wollen es natürlich
alles schall billigt datenschutz können
können sie auch mandy kommt kaum gehen
und einfach mal diese nummer hier
eingehen geben und dann haben sie drei
auswahlmöglichkeiten können sie mal ihre
assoziationen einfach eingeben was mit
virtueller realität verbinden und dann
bin ich gespannt was sie dazu sagen ich
gebe diese sache auch noch meine chat
ein da führten sie die adresse und da
finden sie auch die nummer und jetzt
will ich einfach mal auf diese menschen
umfrage dann sehen wir die gleichen
ergebnisse
ja hier kommen interessante begriff
[Musik]
schwindelgefühl trifft 17
angesichts dieser interessanten begriffe
die sich hier anordnen
ich nehme nur ein paar
roboter virtueller raum also der raum
begriff
digitalisierung natürlich
fake leben hatte das feld der schein ist
so eine wiederkehrende assoziation 3d
natürlich auch die 3d brille die
virtual reality brillen die man da so
auf hat über dem kopf
science fiction also futuristische
szenarien
wenn sie an diese schrift über die
zukünftige technologische entwicklung
denken die sie überall lesen können dass
es jetzt bald eigene künstliche
intelligenzen gibt die uns übertreffen
sogar also diese ganzen begriffe hängen
damit irgendwie zusammen wird begriff
der virtuellen realität ist unglaublich
anregen das kriege ich glaube das haben
wir jetzt schon gesehen ich bedanke mich
niemals für die diesen eindruck und geht
es wieder über auf meine anderen
präsentation also wir haben gesehen der
begriff ist ziemlich vielfältig er ruft
sehr viele assoziationen hervor er ist
sogar ein bode worte also virtuelle
realität ist ein modewort geworden und
ich möchte jetzt also ein bisschen
stellung nehmen und eine eigene richtung
verfolgen die mir besonders hilfreich zu
sein scheint für die lehre die wird
jetzt ein bisschen anders aussehen als
das was man sich mit dieser brille
vorstellt es wird ein bisschen
nüchterner aussehen also die neuen
medien verändern nicht nur unsere weise
der wahrnehmung der welt sondern es
energien auch in virtuelle realitäten
das beste beispiel ist in meinen augen
das was wir gerade machen wir machen
hier einen zoom konferenz das ist eine
virtuelle konferenz die nicht raum
zeitlich jetzt gebunden ist an speziell
universitäts räume die sich dank der
neuen medien dadurch dass wir hier
internet haben die hohe geschwindigkeit
gute rechenpower diese technologischen
basis verdanken neue medien werden
selbst zu ökologischen faktoren wie
luciano für ihn bereits angedeutet hatte
in welcher die kommunikations
theoretisch unterscheidung von sender
bzw boote und empfänger immer mehr auf
darum wird das internet ist jetzt meine
these ist nicht so sehr ein medium
sondern vielmehr ein meta medium es ist
die bedingung der möglichkeit von
mentalität wie zum beispiel vom medium
millimeter oder des mediums zoom das
können wir nur nutzen dank dieser
konstrukteur des internets es ist
gewissermaßen ein grundbedürfnis
geworden das internet wie wasser strom
und wärme es ist ein raum in dem sich
die virtuelle realität ereignen und
entfalten kann ich denke auch dass man
das internet zu recht als ein
handlungsraum als ein virtueller
handlungsraum bestimmen kann denken sie
ihre gestrigen tag da ist plötzlich
facebook app instagram ausgefallen ja
wir hatten irgendwie das bedürfnis diese
kommunikationskanäle wieder zu haben ist
würde uns gewissermaßen tat so als ob
man uns die heizung ausgestellt wurde
das wasser abgedreht hat er hat uns also
das virtuelle wasser sozusagen abgedreht
wir sehen es ist zu einer logischen
faktor unserer lebenswelt geworden es
ist nicht mehr nur ein medium wie jetzt
ein brief oder sowas ist seine wirklich
lebens an lebensformen geworden und
jetzt gibt es eben hier ein neues
handbuch was ich sehr empfehlen kann
kostenlose zugriff über das universitäts
netz an buch virtualität im jahr 2020
erschienen dieses handbuch behandelt
ganz verschieden disziplinen kennt sich
der frage nach der bedeutung virtueller
realität also welche bereiche unseres
lebens wir alle virtualisieren können
vor allem natürlich mit hilfe der
digitalen technik so und jetzt möchte
ich hier eine auch wichtige these
markieren virtuelle realität ist in
meinen augen nicht mit simulationen zu
verwechseln also wir hatten hier die
assoziation simulation science fiction
3d brille das ist alles die simulation
ich glaube aber dass virtuelle realität
viel mehr ist als nur simulation obwohl
sie gewisse momente
simulation auch bei ihm hat sagte dieses
handbuch der einleitung folgendes
virtualität hat im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert eine normalisierung in
zahlreichen gesellschaftlichen bereichen
erfahren war das virtuelle noch bis zum
ende des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts von
euphorischen bis apokalyptischen
reaktionen und den menschen in
cyberspace bekleidet hat es zwischen
eingang in zahlreiche standardisierte
praktiken gefunden das virtuelle ist
also nicht länger ein modell für einen
technischen eskapismus aus der
lebenswelt sind sie öffnet eine kaum
überschaubare summe von szenarien des
einstiegs in und des anschlusses an
diese virtualität ist wie das was wir
natur nnen oder was so lange zeit so
genannt wurde teil unseres lebens sind
und das in der fülle aller möglichen
bezüge unter anderem eben auch in der
digitalen lehrt das phänomen der
virtualität wird also immer mehr als
modus von realität und gerade nicht mehr
als eine form von realitätsverweigerung
oder realitätsflucht sichtbar und das
scheint mir für die lehre ganz zentral
sand statt formen der isolation zu
fördern gegen virtuelle realitäten mit
einer fülle neuer und veränderter
interaktionsmöglichkeiten und sozialraum
einher das virtuelle wird auf diese
weise nicht nur zu einem resonanzraum
sozialen phänomenen es wird zum ort der
konstruktion und der aushandlung neuer
sozialität und umgangsformen sowohl von
menschlichen als auch von nicht
menschlichen akteuren virtuelle realität
eröffnet abseits der fluchtmöglichkeiten
eine totale und möglicherweise
totalitäre alte reed einen eigenen raum
verhandlungen erfindungen für handhabung
von gegenständen für fingerfertigkeiten
für interaktionen für sozialen
ökonomischen austauschen dabei möchte
ich jetzt belassen ich bin der meinung
dass das sehr zutreffend ist in diesem
handbuch neutralität konnte leider viel
zu kurz und glauben das ist besonders
dringend die lehre als eine form von
virtualität dank unsere technik
digitalisierung eine eigens zu
thematisieren und darauf kommt es mir
zogen an
verstehen wir das hinter jetzt internet
jetzt nicht nur als ein medium der
wissensvermittlung oder der
informationsbeschaffung sind als einen
virtuellen hand und raum so können wir
es als ein lehr- und lernraum die dachte
weiter bestimmt das internet erlaubt
euch zeitraum zeitliche reibungslos ich
kite also wir sind sie nicht an
bestimmte orte gebunden der wir sind
nicht einer zeit logik unterworfen die
verzögerung groß bedingt gut manchmal
des technischen ex aber im idealfall
nicht uns eine raum zeitliche
reibungslosen verlauf verschiedene
medien ganz verschiedene arzt an
verbindlichen lern kontext zu
fusionieren und so ein gewissermaßen
hyper medium zu konstruieren welches
raum zeitlich unabhängig ist gelernt und
gelehrt werden kann überall zu jeder
zeit es herstellern eine gewissermaßen
ubiquitäre didaktischen präsenz wir
haben das gesehen als es unter fall
gedachte dokumentation von lehre und
lernen ging einem jahr das ganze
fixieren und können es dann nach eigenem
rhythmus nach individuellen bedürfnissen
rezitieren und gegebenenfalls eben auch
kommentieren und teilen es sind damit
nicht mehr so sehr die einzelnen inhalte
des lehrens und lernens die fahne die da
gibt der digitalität wie man sie nennen
könnte entscheidungen sind als vielmehr
die nicht-lineare wege und formen ihrer
verbindung die unserer freiheit einer
heim bestimmt ist also diese
flexibilität des virtuellen
handlungsrahmens das internet zeigt sich
besonders für die lehre und das lernen
aus
das ist also meine these verstehen oder
das internet als einen virtuellen lehre
und lernen durch der durch die
kategorien der digitalität also diesem
raum und zeit local stimmt es so können
wir gedanken mentale gedanken und
gehalte auf eine besondere weise ext
analysieren die nicht mehr allein dass
die erzeugung subjekt gebunden sind sie
kennen alle das teilen von informationen
das dokumentieren das kommentieren das
leid und das sind alles formen der
externalisierung von mentalen gehalten
es entsteht zu einem gedanken auf und
kontext und welchen sich jedes lehrende
und lernende das objekt einklinken kann
die lehr und lern kontext der auf basis
des internet steht erweist sich damit
als eine netzstruktur die immer weiter
entwickelt werden kann unabhängig vom
träger der gedanken dies bedeutet dass
eine didaktik der digitalität ihren
blick vom individuellen zuge des lernens
immer mehr abfinden und hin zum
kollektiv des vernetzten lernens und
lehrens wenden auch die traditionelle
unterscheidet und lehren und lernen wird
durch die vernetzung struktur das
internet immer mehr verflüssigt wenn
auch nicht gänzlich aufgehoben die
lernsituation der digitalität ist nicht
die eine front ali-t von einer
reibungslosen
horizontal i tät die sich eben diesen
hyper medien des internets prozent so
jetzt gepräge ein paar beispiele diese
didaktisch horizontal i tät im gegensatz
zur quali tät kann insbesondere durch
ein interaktives semantisches witschi
realisiert wird also durch über
textuelle verknüpfen diese lassen sich
mit frei verfügbaren software
realisieren es gibt diese open
software es gibt andere software da ist
jetzt niemand die frage wie man es nutzt
ein seminar inhalt wird so zu einem
kooperativen projekt welches sich
lernende und lehrende gleichermaßen
interaktiv einbringen können eine
beteiligung der lernenden im zimmer des
hypertext den netzen von inhalten mit
anderen inhalten ist dabei nicht nur als
ein formaler technische aktie verstehen
sondern vielmehr selbst integraler teil
des lernprozesses im virtuellen raum als
ein ursprüngliches internet also ein
gekapselt es jetzt kann sich ein solches
seminar wiki mit der zeit auch mit
anderen externen wikis vernetzen und zu
einem überweg fusionieren wir hatten das
auch schon anderen vorträgen wird dass
man hp inhalte gerne auch teilen kann
und so einen größeren kontext erzeugen
kann
so jetzt dann habe ich schon gesagt dass
diese neuen medien diese strenge
unterscheidung von lernenden und
lehrenden von produzent und rezipient
immer weiter aufgeht hier gibt es jetzt
ein neues phänomen youtube dass ich
verzehr geeignet halten welches auch
nicht so sehr als eine medienplattform
als schlimmer als ein virtueller
vermittlungs raum zu verstehen ist auf
youtube verwischen die grenzen von
rezeption produktion immer mehr da die
hürden einer publikation einer
präsentation viel geringer sind und sich
so auch andere lehrende und lernende mit
einbeziehen lassen hier ist natürlich
wieder die didaktische offenheit zu
betonen die es erlaubt verschiedene
medien anzubinden youtube videos kann
überall hinein eingebunden werden
natürlich dürfen wir zum schluss auch
nicht immobilien formen des virtuellen
lehrens und lernens vergessen die sich
insbesondere durch apps zeigen auch da
wurde zu beginn im vortrag von frontier
trust den ich oben rechts ein verlinke
darauf hingewiesen sie hat das etwas
skeptischer gesehen nicht in der meinung
apps eignen sich hervorragend als
ergänzung der virtuellen lehre nämlich
als eine art von seminar für die großen
taschen oder die westentasche oder was
auch immer die kriterien lehren und
lernen bedeutet die zunehmende
entkoppelung von raum zeitlichen
vorgaben und beschränkungen und damit
die individualisierung und zugleich auch
endlich die visualisierung des lern und
der platz ist das market paradox klingt
einerseits hängt das nicht nur an
einzelnen personen weil es hat dieses
netz ins dieses gemeinsame wissens
lernen andererseits können sich jedem
individuum gerade deswegen auch viel
besser persönlich mit ihren lehren und
lernen verhandlungen weil es unabhängig
von äußeren faktoren ist man autonom ist
im prozess des lebens und lanz
jetzt bringe ich am schluss noch ein
paar beispiele aus der praxis aus meiner
eigenen auf die habe ich auch schon
vergangenen tagen hingewiesen zunächst
diesem pikierte dieser wg struktur hatte
ich ein wiki seminar man sieht hier auch
seine begriffswolke die sich danach
richten wie häufig die begriffe
verwendet wurden wie sieht man überblick
das ist also wikipedia
nachgeahmt dann muss man mehr als 1000
16 dann habe ich kennen sie bestimmt
auch schon diesen youtube-kanal philo
cast gegründet die jetzt immerhin
umfasst also 4200 abonnenten hat hier
eignet sich der kanal sehr gut dazu neue
sendungen wie auch die letzten dieser
war ein bisschen konferenz darauf zu
stellen und der kommentierung
freizugeben auch hier edwin interessante
diskussion statt und zum schluss möchte
ich noch auf die app hinweisen da wir
auch eine fast app erstellt die auch
schon über tausend mal heruntergeladen
wurde die natürlich nicht ausschließlich
genutzt werden kann die sich aber in
kombination mit den anderen medien wie
blogs youtube und wikis ist als sehr
fruchtbar herausgestellt hat so das war
mein vortrag vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und ich bin gespannt auf
die diskus